i always thought you know a snowshoe
would really make a great cello a wooden
chair back
makes a cool guitar body it turns out
that one of my
most playable instruments is is a golf
club i'm seeing that transformative
quality in my head all the time
what can i say i'm attracted to trash i
don't know why
[Music]
check out the jimi hendrix of shovel
it's a guitar made up of lots of well
junk he even plays his zipper from
brooklyn new york please welcome ken
butler
my name is ken butler i'm an artist and
musician and known for building my own
experimental instruments
since 1978 i think i've made around
400 instruments
this whole thing started for me when i
was in my basement in portland oregon
and i saw a rusty
old beat up hatchet
put two strings and two tuning pegs on
it plugged it into my guitar amp and was
quite stunned that it actually sounded
like a horrible violin
the axe violin was the first time that
somebody said
that's a cool idea
if i go walking around the neighborhood
everywhere you look you see such amazing
conglomerations of potential sculpture
there's crutches tennis rackets parts of
furniture boom i'm right there with that
you know when i build stringed
instruments
really just need three things
the head
the neck
and
the body
a spoon
has that parameter a key
looks like a guitar is you know and then
there's the little body
this is from a
very inexpensive mandolin of course some
of the things become
crazy baroque assemblages of multiple
multiple necks it's ridiculous but
that's how it works
my shovel guitar i guess it's a small
snow shovel
it's just a quirky object and it sounds
unbelievably beautiful the qualities and
character that the golf club has is
amazing
there's one that's made from a beach
paddle that has a
ukulele neck and a cane
sometimes people think my intention is
humor it's not i think it's surprising
to people that i can generate genuine
emotion and meaning and real music on
something as ridiculous as
a hockey stick or a tennis racker or a
broom or a shovel or a golf club
at the real core of what i'm doing it's
to communicate to other people that the
things right around them can be magical
and transformative and even spiritual
who knows if if i hadn't found that ax
what would have happened
[Music]
you